[Music]
Americans are increasingly connected to
the virtual world through phones
computers and smart appliances
now even vital utilities like power and
water grids are going digital only on
CBS this morning we got access to a
massive power plant near Niagara Falls
New York
it's upgrading its systems with
artificial intelligence that is raising
concerns among some security experts
about the dangers from hackers
Errol Barnett shows us how power plants
can defend themselves good morning
cybersecurity firms are tracking an
increased number of attempted attacks on
US infrastructure with one identifying
at least eight groups of state-sponsored
hackers meanwhile our homes are linked
to the grid through smart thermostats
and other connected devices so to see
what the risks are I explored New York
State's high-tech utility infrastructure
which is now becoming more reliant on
artificial intelligence to see how our
grid is protected from attack we are now
layering new technologies to this system
that was built back in the 1960s
old-school hydropower is getting a
new-school upgrade thanks to artificial
intelligence New York State's largest
power plant harnesses the awesome energy
of the Niagara River and now the New
York Power Authority or Napa is
connecting this plant and miles of
transmission lines with tens of
thousands of sensors which can
essentially think so if there are
anomalies or if the temperature is
outside the range of design this sensors
will communicate automatically to our
integrated smart Operations Center the
AI network reaches statewide warning not
only of problems on the grid but
predicting where unscheduled maintenance
is needed the aim is to lower costs and
to pass savings on to customers with all
data processed and verified here by
computer engineers with the improvements
of software and computing power you also
have the increase in potential risks
from cyberattacks how do you protect
against that absolutely
we have to think about cyber at every
step of the process we have to
incorporate cyber defenses in every step
of the software and hardware that we're
putting together there's more risk than
we've ever had before Rob Lee spent most
of his military career at the National
Security Agency and now runs his own
consulting firm after sounding the alarm
about weaknesses in the u.s. grid to
Congress he is critical of States
relying on AI systems and computer
networks in general the communication
paths that a house might open a path for
adversary to take advantage of as well
Lee led the US military's investigation
into the Russian hack of the Ukrainian
power grid in 2015 made possible he says
by a simple internet connection they
opened up circuit breakers and
de-energize portions of grid leaving
225,000 customers or so in the darkness
for a couple hours Lee warns AI without
highly-skilled humans involved is risky
what are the vulnerabilities it opens up
you don't want your grid operators that
humans that are controlling your grid to
become so dependent on the machine
learning or AI model that they forget
how to do their jobs
these systems are thinking they're
making decisions what do you say to
people who are concerned about that
there are still humans in between the
information and the actions so think of
this really as a very smart decision
support system now we weren't allowed to
show you but Gil tells me their power
plant control rooms have safeguards and
operate on a completely different
network from the rest of the grid still
the Department of Homeland Security
revealed earlier this year
Russian malware was opened by someone in
a power plant control room via email it
was as simple as that
and that's why you have this growing
consensus that it is critical to
increase the skills of everyone plugged
into the network Anthony thanks Errol